hello guys welcome back to million show
today we are going to talk about my
favorite topic which is football I'm
going to tell you the statistic of
Albania in Euro 2024 and how far we have
gone from the last year Albania this
season have been a very good team they
have went up on the way far rankings
from the 64th team in the world to the
22nd team in the world and they are the
first on the point table with 13 points
they have showed a really great
performance this season scoring a lot of
goals outside of the 60 meter range
especially a player called yaser
asani their first match in Euro 2024
qualifiers was against Poland they have
played team in the World Cup qualifiers
as well where they have lost to them
twice in the first match of the
qualifiers we lost to them again one Zer
where Poland player called swederski
scored the goal versus Albania we
totally had three shots on goal seven
shot attempts and 45% ball possession
while Poland had five shots on goal 11
shot attempted and 55%
possession that was was very sad to see
because we were hoping that we might
actually change the history and beat
them this time but it seems we just
couldn't the second MCH day of Euro 2024
was versus mova where this time we
actually won to zero and the goals were
scored by yaser asani and edim bami in
which Yas asani scored an absolute
Banger outside of the 16 top
Corner we totally had five shots on goal
12 shot or attempted and
72% ball position while mova only had
one shot on our goal eight shot
attempted and 28% ball possession which
tells us that we have a really good
defense M day three was versus far
Island and we had the advantage since in
the UFA rankings we are ranked before
them so it was expected for us to win in
this match we won this match 3-1 for us
where the scores were bami chistian
sonon and eres muchi and the far player
we scored for them which his name is
odar
Faro in this match we had six shots on
goal 19 shots attempted and 49% ball
possession while farro Island had only
two shots on goal nine shot attempted
and 51% ball
possession this match was an expected
win for us s uh since I wasn't really
that happy since we won cuz I was
expecting Albania to
win Mass day 4 is where things starts to
get interesting because we're going to
play
against CET Republic and everyone was
expecting us to lose since C Republic
had just beaten Poland on this year 2024
qualifiers so everyone thought we were
not that good to win this game but we we
actually managed to take a draw with
them which is a really really good and
is really on our favor since the match
was held on C Republic and not a lot of
albanians were there so we didn't a lot
have a lot of motivation to win this
game but we still managed to get a one-1
draw the score the goal was scored by
nedan barami and the C republ player V
VAV
Carney what is crazy about this draw is
that c Republic had four shots on goal
11 shot attempted and 57% ball
possession and only scored one while us
albanians only had one shot on goal one
shot attempted which was which was
another Banger from Nim bami outside 60
m in 43% ball position and we managed to
do a one-1 draw with them which is
honestly
crazy match day five in match day five
we were versus Poland so we had to remas
them again and we actually won two Z
this time since the game was held in our
home Poland actually scored one but it
was called offside so it didn't count
the ones who scored for AA where yerani
and
milanu where we had three shot on goal
seven attempted shots and only 39% ball
position while Poland had two shot on
goal 12 shots attempted and 61% ball
position this just goes to show what a
great defense and attack Albania have
right now after milanu scored what was
crazy was that he took off his shirt and
he had a tattoo which was Katana 138
that tattoo indicates usaka soldiers who
died fighting to protect Kosovo from
serbians I don't really want to go into
politics but I want just to say that
serbians weren't really that happy for
that to that Marland dark W
made and by the way what's with Albania
the only score bangers it's so
entertaining to watch them because more
of their go most of their goals are like
from really really far away always the
outside of 60 M especially yerani and
nedim barami they're scoring they're
scoring some bangers this
season the last match which has happened
until now in year 2024 qualifiers is
Albania against C Republic we had a
rematch last time we were in the draw
1-1 this time we actually managed to win
30-0 be uh the goals were scored which
where the goals were scored from Yasir
assani and which was another Banger by
the way and two other goals were scored
from t
s an important reason to why we won this
match is because we were in our home
field and we had a lot of more
motivation since a lot of banians went
to the stadium to watch this
play we totally had four shots on goal
eight shots attempted and only 35% ball
possession which goes to show what a
great defense and attack we
have while clette had seven shots on
goal 13 shot attempt and 64% ball
possession I think that we are basically
qualified for this Euro 2024 since the
last two matches will be against mova
and Faro Islands which will be played in
November from the statistic we have a
really uh good stati statistics against
them so I think this will be too easy uh
wins for
Albania the only bad thing that I'm sad
about is that Kosovo doesn't have that
much chances to qualify for this year
2024 qualifiers since they have gotten
way too many draws and losses two teams
they were uh ranked higher than them in
UFO rankings their first match was
against Israel where they have gotten a
draw which is very good since everyone
was expecting Israel to win since they
were the favorite uh and so we managed
to actually make a draw with them the
second match was against andur where I
myself went to watch that game and I was
disappointed I remember that adona grova
scored the first first goal but right
after that andura scored one goal and
made it 1-1 which was not fa favorable
for us since we were expected to win
this the third match was against
Romania another draw a really boring
match 0 there wasn't that much action
next up is against bellus where we had
to win this game but we actually lost to
them 2-1 which is honestly depressing
since bellaris is like one of the lowest
ranking teams and we actually lost to
them next up was kova versus Switzerland
and kova actually managed to surprise me
this time because they managed to get 2
two versus them scissorland is known for
being one of our highest teams in W our
rankings and we managed to do a draw
with them I still didn't lose my hopes
for Kosovo and I thought we were going
to win but we lost again to Romania two
Z so the whole hopes for us to qualify
for year 2024 are basically
over so to wrap things up I want to
thank you all for hearing my podcast
today and I hope you have a great
day